uh i do want to continue kind of um
going at the
opening section that i started doing
last week because i've been wanting to
do this for like
a month now and so i'm just going to
continue it um we are talking kind of
about my experience with french garokan
uh and pierce which are
all kind of embedded in negi's book so
i'm i guess advertising for him so yeah
feel free to buy his book
uh he's pretty good when it comes he's
his great brain and i mean the book is
like what five oh six years
seven years now oh my god the book is
getting old
but i still place on this line and i
still love it so
uh i do think it is definitely worth it
also thank you for the follow be sure to
continue supporting us with your follows
and subscribes and
that side of it now uh last week we
talked about
this beauty
on youtube so if you haven't uh checked
it out make sure to take your time and
do that so this was a specific game that
i showed it was a beautiful game i loved
it i won it
and i gave you analysis on my take on
this specific opening as well
now
i want to kind of switch things up and
talk about french for a little bit to be
fair i did show a bit of french
about three weeks ago on twitch so this
is going to be more of a build up on
that
and to kind of build upon this as well
it would be really really great if you
have any like french peer
philidor or carlocan games that you want
to submit for the next hour that will
make that will just kind of top it off
for our class
but for now i kind of want to show you
some sidelines right now
so what are i kind of want to see uh
chat what are some of the i'm also
people here what are some of the
sidelines that you kind of see here what
do you think are some of the ideas black
can do
there's so many of them so
what are we thinking
i hear it dan
how are you
i mean they say there's a lot of options
oh yes
kind of
[Laughter]
c5 look
c5 is the best one but you can also take
here you can also like start with knight
e7 there's some weird b6 stuff so
there's options
so
maybe let's start with
take if they do take when we take back
you know that kind of takes away the
stress of a3 so now
we can continue considering visually 3
instead you know that definitely helps
us so taking before we play a3 is
definitely
not a good idea for opponents it also if
they do find knight e7
it is kind of a transposition to this 97
ideas you know you play queen g4 they
can either castle or queen c7 and that's
again transposition to the main lines
um
but what if b6
what do you think about this
in french especially in winover these b6
are very
kind of annoying because if opponent can
play visual basics and exchange these
two
yeah you have to be exactly you have to
be quite careful about that so what do
you think we should do
can we really stop bishop basics
also it's so cold here
it's rainy but it's humid but somehow
i'm always freezing
so what do you think white should do
c4 c4 is definitely an interesting
choice but
that's not the only one so because this
bishop is no longer on f a it means g7
pawn is kind of an easy target so we
definitely want to keep attacking this
and then another option that we can kind
of continue is this h4h5 ideas because
again
a huge part of our advantage is kingside
slash center
so we want to be able to use this
advantage here
now
again h5 is totally fine
black can try and stop our pawn push but
now what do you think we should do is
white should we
accept the change x
exchange
or should we try and
block it with like knight e2 what do you
think we should do as white
we should accept it because
that's fair yeah that's a good option
so in
yes i agree we should take take and then
develop the night and you know it's kind
of a chill opening you're gonna probably
go bishop g5 at some point decide how to
continue should we go pawn f4 should we
go knight f4 you have a lot of options
and white is just a slightly better but
it's not that huge of a
advantage
so
uh in this game i chose the one knight
e2 and i'm not the biggest fan of it to
be honest but let's look into it anyways
nice e2 um okay yeah opponent played
weird you know something like um queen
d7 would have been more supportive for
him
but
in this case
now let me ask you what should whites do
i'm just going to show you maybe two or
three more moves of this game because i
still want to take my time on the other
lines but for now what do you think
white should do
also then if you're still here can you
move there so i can actually see you so
i don't have to
no no no hiding
he's not hiding he's right here
see i brought him sunflower seed so he
has to sit somewhere eat them and stay
where he is
of course i i tried to find beef jerky
with popcorn but i guess we're all out
of it
i couldn't find it
well
next week
so what do you think white should do
does anybody want to do anything in the
king side
i would say center but center is pretty
locked so
okay see yeah um
father
in real life well nice
uh yeah that's kind of that's what i
went for i tried to like move this coin
i tried to go f3 g4 and that was i mean
that was fine but it wasn't the best
idea uh f
four is quite interesting
again it's really hard to envision when
you want to play f5 in this case
but the point is you don't have to
envision it you just got to do it
and when they take now you can get some
e6 ideas now you can try to consider
like moving the queen away getting ready
for you know getting a knight to move
pushing over here it is a lot of stuff
but um
in my game i just couldn't see this f4
f5 working out so i didn't do it
but it would be a nice pawn sacrifice so
i just went like queen f queen e3 and
then i just tried to go for this
and it really made the position over
complicated because yeah it's fine but
at the same time it's
like i can't make the attack work and we
played for another like 20 moves and it
ended in a draw which is still hurtful
when i think about it because
that was one of the years that i was
really really trying for norm and i had
i would play these tournaments and i was
like
this close to getting it and then i
would make a draw with somebody and it
wouldn't happen and anyways so i believe
this was a 2015 game oh 2015
it was great for my rating not that
great for my title but
yeah anyways
i remember 2015 at some point i had like
23 like 50 and then i went to 2190 and
then i went to like 23 like 60 or 70 and
then i came back it was crazy
so i'm so glad to be done with
the crazy k-40 or 20 whatever it was so
all right
so that's one of the things i wanted to
show
the other so objectively were we
supposed to take on a6 are we supposed
to play 92 take on a6
now the other thing is this weird b6
how do you feel about it
to be fair i really don't like it so if
you play with me don't play that
i'm happy to see it as a white
really
okay
oh there's
[Laughter]
okay
so yeah the main thing is just avoiding
that trade completely
make sure their bishop just stays bad
yeah i agree but when they play b6 you
don't really get a choice
right tell unless you actually know what
you play like rightly
g3 but it seems terrible yeah i agree
that does
so queen g4 is quite interesting and i
just when opponent plays bishop of
fights i just wanna like shake him i i
know i can't legally do that but it's
just so annoying because dude you just
play the show for bishop b4 just let the
bishop be even if you want to move
something just go king f8
but you know bishop of fate kind of
i guess that has that thing because i
want to punish them immediately but i
can't punish them immediately so
yeah
i'm not saying you should go play this
by the way but
if you're trying to you know annoy the
opponent just one or two games yeah can
start with special effect all right so
this special fight what do you think is
a good move for white because now i have
two pieces that i've already developed
you know i have that queen on g4 i have
that knight on c3 but opponent hasn't
really developed at all
is a four two weird like if we actually
want to stop bishop a6 which
like it's not that dangerous but if we
stop right we could play a for now
could the other options that you can
also consider is like this
or you can try this and then you can
kind of like surround it
[Music]
something to consider yeah that bishop
just feels so weird
yeah but i also don't want to exchange
them
i just want to put this bishop on d3 and
just like smack the other bishop
out of a6 so what's wrong with day four
to stop bishop a6 oh let's talk about it
what are you gonna do knight b5 they're
happy to trade they should regardless
yeah that's true but also now you're
always gonna have to stay here and deal
with this night
okay i'll go h5 first
i mean if they're better options
because when we play knight c3 we allow
this sort of stuff
but it's like there's not much like if
we play e5
if we play e5 right away
because then we can play c3 and then if
they try to do this b6
yeah that's that's true but then again
you kind of have to deal with like this
is a whole different strategy a whole
different opening right and i have
played e5 you know this c3 a3 ideas
they're pretty cool i mean it's
definitely worth looking into it
but it's very limited
like the
um
in the winter in like this knight c3
idea there is much more room to deal
with like yes same pawn structure but a
lot of different um
strategies you know um if opponent tries
to cast telephone of thrust you go c5 if
upon it if like you know a lot of the
times we don't even cast though we just
keep the king in the middle of the
center and it's i feel like i would get
much more interesting positions
in vinover than i would get
in um
well most of the other friends i just
use them too dry
yeah
so that's one thing to keep in mind now
oh no no let's go b6 so looking at this
b6
i do like bishop b5 i feel like it's
kind of a
interesting try
and yeah if opponents place bishop d7 on
great we'll just bring it back good luck
number bishop a6 haha
but if they play like c6 then they also
kind of move this pawn
too early and in a square that they
wouldn't want to so that's something
that i could potentially you know get
happy about now i do want to talk about
this maneuver for a second i just want
to see how you guys feel about this
so actually yeah how do you feel about
this
i see some i don't like it
i don't mind it c5 is not going to get
played
soon final step would be five
i mean it's gonna happen eventually but
i mean
that's fair also i'm kind of freezing
over here can somebody raise the
temperature by like five degrees at
least
yeah
it's supposed to be light
it's never locked
it's locked i'm gonna
freeze i think it's the window me
sitting here
thank you
all right
now
let's talk about something weird a5 you
know it's not that weird because it has
some bishop
eating ideas
now what do you think we should do
we're talking weird french stuff today
so might as well get them out of the way
so what do you think we should do
i like bishop e3 more than i can play a4
yeah
exactly yeah
all right now what do we do with the
knights
we have options
yeah let's bring the knight to e2
now the thing is
again your position is a little more
disorganized than i would have wanted to
be
but in the long run
the
my uh my
ideal thing would be to kind of lock up
the queen side center and just go
bananas on the king side
so since there is already this lock and
there's already this lock
um the only thing i kind of have to
worry about is a c5 c4 happening so i'm
already kind of considering maybe when
should i play this when should i try and
play this so it's a lot of stuff to
consider
but ultimately keeping that big picture
in mind that we would love to block this
whole abcde and just go crazy on fgh
that's what you would want to do and
yeah exactly i see in the chat this
could also be something we could
consider because this would be the ideal
diagonal for our bishop so
all right let's say bishop a6 now what
do you do
oh i see a few first time chapters hello
also if you're watching us without
following please follow so everybody
else can see that caleb chasing chicken
thingy
i really need the original footage of
that
do you have it yeah i failed it let me
meet ben filmed at jonathan's house
that's actually the backyard of dramas
no i don't know if this is right i would
play knight g3
so i could play like f4 f5 down the road
and just avoid this trade so you can't
take my knight with his bishop but then
i
i am restricting myself
because the bishop is not going to be
traded so i don't think they keep you
here though
i think 92 is okay the only thing that
kind of makes me think is this
you know i don't want to leave my queen
side completely
the you know
without any defenders because then when
you get c5 you if you play c3 then this
can get too
hopeful
yeah too hopeful for opponent to open
yeah so i think it's good idea to just
keep the knight here for right now
and then um
we can try and maybe develop this guy
one way to do this knight history
and the idea with knight h3 is
actually let me think about it
because i was going to say maybe we can
push the f-bomb bringing f2 but i
actually don't like that
how about knight f3 oh actually we were
talking about the c5 so i don't want c7
let's just go bishop v3
that makes more sense
to kind of stop these ideas even if you
try to push more for it i can still try
to protect my
no if they take we take that's totally
fine because we can always like fake
castle if needed yeah
so that's okay
but um so kind of we're still thinking
about long-term ideas
and if we can get this side locked
that's great
the computer was showing some weird
stuff with like long castle i don't know
how i feel about that to be honest
i i wouldn't play this in a real game
yeah i wouldn't do it
sorry you're just hoping that it stays
locked up inside
yeah but they definitely gonna do c5
sooner or later so why am i putting
myself through this
partially yeah
the other thing that i was trying to
decide is when to play h4 because i do
want to consider h4 because if i get h5
i'm good but the problem is in french
whenever you play h4 opponents could
technically just go h5 and
kind of mess with your dreams so that's
another thing to keep in mind
so i'm kind of sick of this b6 let's
move on to something else but we have a
few ideas what to do with v6
that's good enough for now because we're
just kind of giving brief introductory
to
the crazy stuff
okay
let's go c5
now i kind of want to talk about this
for minutes just because again i managed
to
get myself into a
losing game
in 2015
2015 was such a i played like
almost 200
more than 200
rated classic games so it was just crazy
and i was just playing way too much
and again my rating did go pretty high
up but my um
i feel like my chest kept going back and
forth
so yeah um
this actually happened to me in one of
the last rounds in uh bl 2015
and i ended up losing and it was very
very painful because again i was close
to norm because i had drawn like a 2650
the first round i had beat like at 2400
so i was on track for norman
so what do you um what do you think what
should we do
yeah i couldn't completely remember my
b4s so i was like you know what i'm
going to go with something safer i'm
going to go queen g4 there's no way this
is bad and it's not bad but it's not
theory and the plan started to equalize
really fast and
yeah this was not pretty
see the position is still comfortable
but there's so many little problems with
it that's upon you know so not so many
hanging stuff so many uncomfortable
pawns yuck
so yeah
i ended up actually losing this game
i'm still pretty fine but
for example i had to choose to play king
e2 right now
come on
like why why would i like
rook history feels much more comfortable
because you're kind of getting the rook
involved you're not pinning your own
king over here
so but the problem was now queen b2 and
then i have to move this and then that
falls and this is a whole deal to do
ah yeah that was sad
anyways
so i'm just gonna talk about the theory
for just very briefly so no point g4 b4
is a good idea now they can take here
they can take there let's talk about
this one first what should we do
that's one of the options
i'm trying this thing do we want queen
g4 before knight b5 or do you want to
just go knight b5
any thoughts feelings
why can't we just take the bishop well
we can but they take over here
then this is kind of wobbly
if you go over here
then
you always have this nasty king effect
it's not
not doable
but that's not the that's not the way to
punish
well not that before definitely first if
they take i kind of do like queen g4
and the king gotta move because if you
don't if you play g6 well that just
gives me even more um
ideas with how to attack you and how to
use these weaknesses what if i played 97
instead
now so 97
it's the same
but i don't i don't have to take it
that's kind of thing
because right now when you play when you
play 97
um
actually i could
let's say if we take this first they
take them i take you go here i take
you're gonna what take this oh that's
not the best idea now because this kind
of feels very similar to the
oh my god i can't remember the name of
that
it's
the poison
doesn't actually have a name
is the name of the poison pond
i should have beat myself up for not
knowing the
name for that poison pond line because
it's actually called the poison pawn
line
it does feel a lot like that but i guess
the difference is when the queen is on
c7
it's already attacking this guy but now
it feels like i have an extra tempo to
deal with it however i want
now i don't have to go knight e2
immediately i could go knight f3
i could choose when to play f4 or h4 so
it gives me more options so i definitely
like that
on c7
but also the white c3
yeah
so that's one thing to consider um
so let's say they go king f8 now we have
this 9p5 this is looking quite promising
though
yeah this is more my move
i guess knight f3 is good too just going
at this but then knight c6
maybe bishop v2 still can't eat this
because of this
and
this is i think a comfortable position
i don't think you're that much better
but you're also your opponent is very um
definitely more uncomfortable because a
lot of these ideas that they would have
revolves around c4 but now there's no
more c c5 for them they don't have c5
anymore and they're they're on castle
but i'm not so soon i can do this bishop
d3 this bishop is still kind of sucky so
i'm very comfortable with this
then it looks uncomfortable
oh i was just wondering i was trying to
figure out why didn't go bishop c7
oh well i guess first thing first i
could take it
think knight d6 is that huge of a deal
to if i'm being honest
because yes knight d6 is something that
we would like
but
since the king has already moved i don't
really need knight d6 to make it work
does that make sense hopefully
okay great
okay
let me go so that's that's something i
wanted to talk about
for
where was i
this one let's say they take b4 now what
do you do
now this is i think i have more fun in
this one to be honest
what do you think is the best option
here
okay what should we do what do you think
black should do
is there anything that kind of concerns
your position
see there are multiple things
thing number one
they could take
right
thing number two they could push that's
a check
thing number three they could develop
attack
so few options for us to consider
so
what are we thinking
anything specific in mind
nobody wants anything specific in this
line
well maybe bishop c7 or knight c6
i mean i'm just
i don't want the 96 to happen again but
that's fair
well
let's talk about this one let's say they
go knight c6 what do you do
first
but they're you you're
that's fine but you're also kind of
leaving this side kind of hanging
right i'm basically saying if they push
or take then i'm just gonna play
there should be two i'm just gonna
it's too overextended i'm just gonna win
it back eventually but
you know
so what is your main idea
my main idea is if they take or push i
was just going to claim that their pawns
were extended
okay and i'll win it back eventually but
right it doesn't really resolve it
instantly right
yeah i feel like we don't need knight d6
just yet we could
always just go like bishop d2 block this
bug this first if they do if they push
it well that's great i can just take if
they take it i can simply activate my
rook too so i feel like i'm just a
little bit more comfortable with this
right and then i have 96
i guess my thought process was if uh
this happened and i played rook takes a
three day we just
played
efficiency seven after b takes a3
um
so bishop c7
now my rook is really active and this is
a whole different problem that you have
to deal with
i feel like the threat of knight d6 is
stronger than the actual move because
when you play knight d6 they're gonna
play king f8 so
i feel like it might be easier to
push them to play king f8 with
queen g4
because unless you're going here to take
this that knight is not super stable
there so
right and i don't want to take that
exactly yep i agree
all right
so
um
that was like the knight c6 idea but
like yeah you can also consider b3 which
you can do this
you can consider take which again you
can do c3
so
yeah the main thing that i wanted to
definitely mention is efficient a5 you
got this cool b4
i manny i also agree yes it is
it is a little um i guess scary when you
are giving your opponent that open um
will not open that pass pawn on a file
for a long future but
since it's so long in the future i'm
kind of hoping we'll checkmate them
before it gets there
so
all right um now i want to try and show
other crazy stuff let's say they take we
take
now there was this one crazy idea
i really really liked
where is my crazy stuff ah
ooh
i already kind of talked about this
queen a5 but i'm just gonna show it
again just because it brings me such
pleasure every time i show this
so uh
again it's a specific opponent i had
prepared this because i remember this
was like
2014
every time i talk about anything
past
2017 it just makes me feel so old the
other day someone was asking me um how
long have been playing chess and i was
like well i knew the moves when i was
like i knew the pieces when i was two
but i wasn't really playing so i uh like
i started playing when i was six and
then it hit me it's been almost 18 years
my chess career could be on is it
becoming an adult soon
yeah
anyways
so um
yeah one of the biggest things that
helped me in this 18 years has been just
kind of preparing
for the any opponent so if i know i'm
playing you i will be preparing for you
so the best shot to you guys to surprise
me
which hops happens a lot in american
tournaments anyways um
that was kind of a big thing that
does help me like preparation helps me
and it's like a you know it's like when
the teacher would say hey make sure to
note these like last year's exams i'm
gonna repeat something it feels like
that so you should go for it
anyways um
this specific game i had prepared a
little bit because well i took and
that's not necessarily the best idea
but i really really wanted to well
actually hold on i wanted to enter this
one in this game in the game that i'm
trying to show you and opponent chose to
well
take that now what do you think is wrong
with that
yeah
i should probably try and hide that but
yeah
or or if they do stuff like that ah
beautiful beautiful
exactly
but see my opponent was really nice i
remember as soon as i played bishop d3
he just looked at the board he kind of
smacked his head he resigned to left and
this was a rated classical game so
i had the whole evening to actually go
swim and go back to town this was in
denmark so it was really beautiful
weather
i like biking
good times
anyways so
that's just something you can consider
if your opponent does this queen 5 idea
this is not the best way to play it but
this is the trickiest way because you
might
be up a queen
in less than 10 moves so if you want to
go for the trick go for the trick
was that your preparation
it was and it happened yeah
exactly oh i should take my cat on bike
actually that's not the bad idea cat on
the bicycle i don't know how he would
how
how he would deal with this he was fine
on the plane he's usually fine in cars
too for a short time
but
captain a bike
ah we'll see
so let's talk about less crazy stuff
let's get this 97 out of the way let's
go queen g4 and now i want to show this
king f8 just because uh so last time we
did this line which was three weeks ago
on twitch we talked about queen c7 ideas
i still have to talk about castle later
on but let's talk about king f8 for
right now because i had a really fun
game in it
torlik i miss my cat too
i can try to show pictures again
actually you know what i might
if you find a good move for white right
now we can go with kitty pictures
that just took a new batch for my mom
recently
so what are we feeling
why to move
i like h4
it's okay h4 is okay
s4 is very doable
but when you play this i mean h4 is good
but it's not
um what negi has in his book i believe
uh h4 is good
but i feel like you kind of show your
hand too early
and
it was quite interesting because i this
is the game that i actually um
encountered and i have fun with
but the problem was that now my you know
i have to keep defending these side and
it kind of messes with my harmony my
peace harmony
i don't want this work on a2
but if i don't play it i have to play
like bishop d2 which again messes with
the peace harmony because a part of me
was hoping to get this
and
definitely kind of
not
what i would dream about bishop on d2
was that bishop doing on d2
so
um in in the game that i had i went
through k2 and i wanted to play the h5
and then i had to move the queen again
and i tried to get some of my pieces
rolling and then i had to deal with this
now
what do you think white should do right
now
again find a good move i'm dying to show
this cat picture
i think in the last game you played
something like f3 and g4 this position
in a position ish like this i feel like
it
does um that was a little different
because now i also kind of have to worry
about potential checks here the rook is
in a weird state
that
if i can get f3 g4 i'm happy but
so we don't we want to we want to avoid
this so what do we do
something like that yeah i went for c4
and it was great and i i i need to show
this
okay wait oh no i can't show it because
it's not the camera from here no
oh man that's fine
i'll just post it on instagram
but i'll give you a little preview
i'm asleep
completely asleep i was actually asleep
and there's a cat right here and he
actually looks as big as i do
and
yeah
it's on my phone
oh
no
no
but
such a great kid
anyways
ah okay
so
c4 was what i did it was really great
and the idea about c4 is i want to try
and delay this
bishop is getting exchanged and i would
also really like to blow up the center
because
well
your king is
more under attack than my king
so
so my opponent took uh
my opponent should have taken d4
which i would probably take over here
and then they could try to weaken my
king and keep in mind i can't take with
this because boom
so then i would have to take the drug
and this would be a little more
comfortable for opponents
but in this case he actually played
queen diesel i i remember he was at high
like almost 2500
i am and
he went for queen d7
and so what i did is i chose to try and
continue blowing up the center
i'm continuing to blow up the center and
now what do you think we should do
also also we're getting closer to the
analyzer game so please have your games
ready
we'll go back nikki i just really want
to show this
this move as
well yes
devil c4 i like it
and after that my you know i blocked
your bishop
i have successfully created a safe
environment for my king i have opened my
rook i love this this was such a
beautiful game
and the rest of the game was really good
too so it was just really comfortable
upon didn't really have much of a
playback but
there was a question about
why black can't take knight takes d4
here black can but if they do then c3
what are you gonna do with this knight
if you go back then i'll definitely take
this
if you don't go back well then i'm gonna
take that
so again because i'm trying to blow up
the center opponent should have tried to
maintain some control over the center by
taking here first
and then trying to mess with my king and
my king safety
so
yeah that's one thing i wanted to show
you and now
for a f finale
i'm gonna talk about boom queen d1
okay i see some nice reactions from the
two people that i can see the other two
hopefully also having fun reactions
um
so coin do you want what do you think
yay nay have you ever done it would you
ever do it i've seen this recommended in
opening explorers but i don't i don't
know why
well i don't know why it's ever
recommended but it doesn't seem like it
just seems like we're making everything
my guess is just trying to analyze we're
gonna play like bishop e3 and then
you're putting over like one
but i really don't know why
so
remember how in the other line with h4
the opponents kept like h5 and i had to
move the queen and then they easily
blocked up whatever my queen wanted to
do right so the idea is your queen's job
here is done for right now
you played point g for upon twenty king
f8
your queen's job is done at the moment
bring it back uh protect your queen side
reorganize your queen side and when your
cl since your coin is not on the way if
when you play h4 you can try and support
it for the pawns you can have an easier
time getting your pieces out because
your queen is not on the way
so
that's kind of the big deal
now let's say i want to place queen a5
now what
let's say queen a4
you can but you're also right with the
queen b1 idea
so
why is this move
recommended then well there are multiple
reasons well
first of all you are
stopping a bunch of stuff that black
would want to do in the queen side so
again you're trying to stabilize the
queen side before you take over the king
side
because the center is blocked if you
just start doing stuff in the king side
opponent is also just gonna start doing
stuff in the queen side so we want to
take away opponent's activity and any
type of counter play
now why queen b1 specifically
well
let's see if it's black to move again
what do you think black wants to do
yes for example another idea could be
something like this
to try and activate the bishop where
like b6 bishop b6 so queen b1 definitely
stops any type of visual activity well i
say definitely whoops sorry
but this is still possible
i mean i would be happy about it
so
that's one thing to keep in mind the
other thing is
let's say they play like b6
bye-bye
i would be very happy about this
let's see what else do i have to
kind of worry about
um
maybe knight c6
stacking here but then again you get
bishop b5
you can just continue developing c4s
could also be coming up
so that would definitely definitely be
something that's we would want to do
so
queen b1 protects your queen side and
also tries to kick away opponents from
the queen side so it's not just
protecting
but also taking control over the queen
side and then soon you're going to be
able to do stuff in the king side like
h4 with like knight f3 you don't have to
castle but since you have the option you
can consider it
so
does that help
every sense great
now queen b1 is great also let me make
sure my alarm is not going to go off
again because
you know i learned to put alarms for
when to clock in when to clock out
but then i forgot to close the alarm
after clocking in or out
but me
yeah
um so queen b1 is definitely a very cool
thing
and
i i'm not the you know i don't really
like it when opponent plays c4 because i
feel like whenever they do this c4
then i don't get bishop d3 and that's
well not what i want but also when they
play c4 they definitely stop these stuff
here now it means i can go bananas on
the king's side so
yeah i don't really like i wish i had
the bishop on d3 before this happened so
and i could keep my bishop in this tank
and all but
that's not the end of the road for this
bishop now you can definitely continue
attacking on the king side this way
you can kind of set it up
and whatever it's appropriate and you
your queen feels like it's done over
here you can swing it to the other side
oh bishop s5 is so pretty
yeah
this feels like
those like games like parking jam that
you have to move this car this side to
get the other car out
is that just that's that's uh you know
that's
yeah i think so i had that i had the
actual like parking jump physically when
i was a kid
dude like move then move this
move this car around so you can move
this car on so you can get that car out
was it just me
i don't think i've never played a game
like that but it sounds plausible
especially
i don't know
maybe it's not american
man
anyways this just like that you know you
keep moving something to open up
something else but
the main thing is at the same time
you're doing this you're also not
letting opponent do whatever they want
so you know you're keeping the stroke
here because it's defending you're
keeping this queen here because it's
defending but at the same time your
queen has the option of jumping to the
other side when it's appropriate whereas
his queen or their queen is just kind of
stuck there they have to move way too
many times to get to
this center slash king side so that's
why this position would be better for us
and definitely more comfortable where is
that king going
played king effect and king i think king
d8 and probably king c7 at some point
oh yeah this is actually a game i have
yeah that was a fun game
ah this was such a pretty game
finally g4 wait
yeah i can take this though
quick question in real life would you
take this
like everything's gonna be so weak
but i don't think i would play a classic
game
it was a classical game and it was a
round it was a norm round-robin
tournament and
would you take it now
well i have my norms yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
no but like when you're playing for
norms and like you're so close to
crossing 2400 they're like 2300 like one
of those like big milestones it's so
stressful
now yeah i would take it
but
when i'm actually playing for like
something big
i don't know actually
i have a very different chess philosophy
these days i'm more about torture so
i guess it's like it's who am i playing
against if i'm playing against a higher
rated player i think i would take this
opponent was slightly higher rated yeah
yeah i think if they're higher rated i
would take if not i would uh i would uh
just play it normal because the higher
rated
they can still mess up the tactics
but if they're a grandmaster an end game
they just have more understanding than
me so
wait what then i was just gonna say i
had better
chances
in a situation tactical skirmish versus
a gm where it's like very tactical
um but if it's like a end game i'm
almost and i'm just slightly worse i'm
almost 100
oh yeah that's fair yeah
but yeah i should have taken it but i
kind of chickened out
but
again i had a very different chest
philosophy
six years ago
this was six years ago oh my god
uh yeah
so yeah i should have taken it but i
didn't that would have definitely scored
me a norm earlier
but
i went for g4 and d4 was fine too but
then opponent got counter play and you
know i had some tactical ideas of my own
but
again opponent kind of didn't have to go
for it
and anyways this game i had advantage
for quite a long time but i had trouble
converting and just slipped away the
game was a draw
ah